hey what's up guys my name is HNO and
welcome to episode 96 or game
programming so we're nearing episode 100
here okay so we're gonna talk about mob
speeds today so last time we took a look
at making our chase our only chase us
when we got too close here he is right
here in the red and as you can see as
soon as we move close to him well bit
closer than that oh no he's after us
okay so the primary problem with this is
that he's kind of too fast right we can
outrun him ever and that's a bit of a
problem so what we're gonna go ahead and
fix that Tay today I guess by actually
wow I mean it's not only gonna be fixing
this that's what I want you guys to get
from this fixing this isn't the only
thing it's gonna be doing it she's gonna
allow us to change the speed of our mobs
because right now they actually just
have a they don't have a speed okay they
just walk on if you go to one if you go
over here to want to okay I'm gonna show
you guys a few things yeah but first of
all if we go into player since that's I
guess our prime example of a mob here
you can see that what we have is X a Y
and we either you know subtract that
stuff we add it and over here in this
over here in um where is it over here in
in this move method here we just add X&Y
a into that and that's how we moved now
if we go into player and we do something
like you know if we move our for example
instead of Y I - - why - equals - that's
twice as fast you'll see that we
actually you know we move up a lot
faster than we move down now you guys
might be like oh okay that's really
simple you know that's easy but it's
really not that simple
because um I wish it was because the
problem is collision starts to kind of
slow down there well not so I don't
screw up we're going a left and we are
going ten blocks per second essentially
what happens is we move really fast what
happens is if we actually ten is
probably not enough here let's see
what's a good I think I'm just find a
good section here so I can demonstrate
one
I'm out it's probably a good one what
will happen sometimes and you have to
get this just right so let's maybe put
this up to 16 let's go up here I'll pop
up okay this is not working for me right
now well you can kind of say that say
look at that
well actually the webbing stop right
here by collision and worse even worse
sometimes is no what will we get stopped
at the wrong place we might also get
transported outside the level so if I
put this up there so many ridiculous
like 46 again you'd probably never want
to move that fast but if I do that what
will happen sometimes you know if ever
this is just not wanting to work all
right so the going outside level stuff
isn't working but what you can see is as
soon as I hit left you know we're not
colliding where we should be
we're colliding like in this case
probably about two blocks right of what
we should be and if I can just find just
the right place here you can see that
right there I mean that's I'm going
where I'm trying to go left here and
it's just not allowing me past this
point and there's all these sorts of
problems with collision okay and that
that's an issue so we want to try and
fix that so how can we do that well it's
actually rather simple if we want to
move faster if we want to move slower it
gets a bit complicated but we'll see
what we can cover today hopefully you
guys will will get this so if we go into
mob let's just close everything else
except for mob and player because that's
what that's what we're gonna be focusing
on and possibly I'm out chaser after we
actually implement the main stuff here
in our collision method what we do is we
check to see if the plot if the position
where the player is going to move to
orden sorry the positions of them where
the mob is going to move to is solid or
not okay that's what we're doing and
that's it now the problem are here is
that um well the problem here is that if
XA is actually just just bigger right if
it's just if it's just bigger than what
it should be then we have a problem
don't we because if XA is let's just say
it
9 then X plus 9 would be if F our
x-value was like I don't know 8 for
example X a plus 9 is 17 so it would
actually skip over the tile that was
between 8 and 16 if that makes any sense
hopefully it does right it would skip
over the tile that is that isn't pretty
much between 8 and 16 because we're
adding 17 to it now to illustrate this
I'm gonna use paint on that because
that's how I roll
to illustrate this I grab a brush here
quickly and if we have like our player
here who's gonna be a blue little entity
over here this is our player right and
then over here what I want to do is show
you guys a tile this is a solid tile
right here or a wall basically now the
width of this wall is 8 pixels our
player right now the way that he moves
right is he has an x position and he
also has an X a X a is essentially X
amount the amount of translation he
receives or shape of course so if X if X
here is 8 right this wall over here
let's just say located at about 8 as
well and this side is 16 since the width
is 8 and 8 8 is 16 if X a here happens
to be 7 then X then a plus 7 is equal to
17 so the player's new position would
actually be 17 which is out here so what
he's done is is actually moved past that
wall so what we need to do right
logically if you think this through as
well what we actually need to do here is
somehow get the player right to actually
instead of just move + 7 + 1 go to kind
of move here first then here first then
here first then here first and then here
finally right we want him to kind of
instead of making one big movement we
want him to kind of make small a lot of
small movements right and if you guys
are pretty bright and I know you guys
are you're probably thinking well a for
loop and that is pretty much it we want
to use a for loop sorry about this
hideous Mouse handwriting here
should get a graphics tablet sorted I've
got one but it's just a you know bother
playing here all the time we needed to
make a full loop that basically goes
through this now now the part where it
gets tricky is very very simple a what
is the increment right how much do we
want to advance it by right one it might
be fine yeah
in fact one is usually what you'd go
with but what if we have something where
well what if we have something where we
want to move the player at a speed of
0.5 this is the player we want to move
this the player at is at the speed of
0.5 if we have a full loop going to 1
the players just not going to move
because if we have AI is less than 1 for
example the speed is less than 0.5 right
and of course we'll have I plus plus I
plus plus is gonna set the interval to
be one all right we can change our plus
positive cost something like I plus
equals five and in the interval would be
five but in this case you know if it's
0.5 we probably have to nudge it down to
something like 0.1 or something but the
thing is that might be too slow like why
on earth if we want to move normally
here by one instead of just moving
normally by one pixel you know / update
essentially we'll be actually moving ten
times the amount but in 0.1 pixel
increments now that's an issue right
because well performance so what I want
you guys to kind of take away from this
little lesson here is that um what we're
essentially gonna do is we're gonna
we're gonna essentially run a bit of an
if check not really but kind of if our
value is greater then you know one it
can still be decimal so it could be one
point five it could be you know one
point six it could be anything right and
we really do have to decide what the
increments are gonna be and that that's
where it gets a bit trickier so the way
that I like to do they do these things
is kind of um well first of all we need
to really make X a and Y a doubles
that's the first thing we need to do and
we also need to make sure that they're
doubles here now this completely won't
matter okay and the reason is that
you know while we will have to change
double here and here we've done this
before okay we have we did it for
particles I'm pretty sure if we go to
particle here then you'll see that in
the collision code yeah we've got
doubles now we've got integers to cast
to it and we got all this code figured
out here we might want to pretty much
copy and paste that into mob here and
get that just just to get that sort of
else wouldn't have to deal with that you
can see it works just right away here
and of course change this to be IX and
iy alright and of course because of that
we might want to change that collision
to be proper as well if we're defeated
in 1/16 I sprites that should pretty
much be pixel perfect here so let's just
test this out right now see if it hasn't
square anything up here in terms in
terms of what collision goes and it's
it's not bad like we are getting a bit
of we want to offset that might be maybe
a little bit here but in terms of actual
collision you know this is this is some
pretty precise collision here again as I
said you you might want to offset the
stuff we can do that later though that's
not an issue and what we kind of want to
do here is over here and where we
actually run this collision card what I
like to do is a bit of a for loop so
what you could do is for in I equals 0
this is just a demonstration by the way
in fact if we separate these completely
probably be a lot better so 14 y equals
0 Y is less than Y a y plus plus all
right we could do a simple shot like
that and then say in that case if
collision is not detected here and the
excess excess color irrelevant here
since we're moving in y but that doesn't
matter
you know then advance on the y axis and
then we could do the same thing for X
now the reason this work well is because
of course if we actually look at the
difference here it's gonna be hard to
illustrate isn't no just because of this
just because this isn't the cleanest way
to demonstrate this let's carry this
code for a minute and just look look at
what it looks like right now if we go
down into where are we if we go down
into over here where we go along we
travel different directions here and we
just boost this first despair by about
10 I feel not try again yeah I say we
move fast now the difference is that um
if I try and find a good amount here you
can see how that's kind of well I'm not
sure if that's even flawed because it's
hard to tell but that's what it looks
like with that essentially on there now
if we were to do something different
where we did something like this instead
on the y-axis here so it would only
increment by one that's important oh
yeah hang on that yes that's important
right and this would also be essentially
um I think collisions well no yeah
collision would be Y as well oh my let
me just figure out collision would be um
yeah why a plus y where Y is no sorry
not why I plus y oh this work is kind of
complicated as well I think it would
just be Y in fast yeah it would be Y
okay and then uh hang on man this should
be this dot y shouldn't
yes and that's how we'll animate that as
well okay so if we take a look at that
what we should get at the same result
here actually no we can actually move
upwards this is also where it were when
it becomes a bit of a problem okay
we need a bit of a method here oh
they're really kind of like an absolute
yes an absolute isn't that because the
thing is if y is less than zero to begin
with we have a problem so math dot ABS Y
a should work let's try that out again
but we're moving down now okay that's an
issue I'm just thinking about the best
fix for this the best fix would probably
be the way that I usually do it honestly
is just making a bit of a method here it
returns an integer called like um our
own ABS and it's gonna taking the value
obviously value here and all it's gonna
do here is it's going to say that if
it's kind of its kind of like absolutely
right it's kind of like ABS but not in
the sense that it returns the actual
values we're just gonna return one
instead of the actual value so in other
words if you know if value is less than
zero it's just gonna return negative one
and if the value is greater than zero or
basically else it's going to return
positive one okay that's all it's going
to do so we've never use a pour more
about two so what that will do here is
for us is instead of y plus plus here
because that would mean there's always
going to be positive we can actually
just plus equals our abs of our value
which is why a okay and well now we'll
do here okay let's change this to double
all right so if we if we check that out
of course what we're gonna get is actual
upper movement and what you should be
able to say we do get stuck sometimes
and that's because we actually haven't
finished it
we're only done that form one axis but
if we move up here you can say that it
actually you know it does it properly
okay now down is a bit of a problem
because of course you know it it do it
properly and down doesn't work properly
yet but if we if we do sort that out by
X&Y I think rather is a problem if we do
the same for X so for int X is equal to
0 X is less and absolute XA x plus plus
and we change this to X local variable
and that can just be why I doesn't only
matter of course we probably get away
with putting that to 0
since we're tracking horizontal movement
here it's not X plus equals ABS XA okay
and then we can here do this completely
and that's really what a method looks
like so if we check that out
hopefully we still get stuff sometimes
that's probably an issue
mmm yeah what do we go I think I might
be with this card here because I haven't
double-checked that why do we get stuck
so why just try sliding in ten
increments of one that should be right X
is the amount that we
I wonder if um I wonder if it's only
happening for up and down let's just
let's change the entire player speed
here to be um ten and we already have
time and see if it happened happens for
other okay doesn't that actually looks
to be worse it's probably a problem
right so let's let's figure out why
that's why that's why that's happening
first of all oh I know why this should
always be one I think oh well yeah this
should always be a BS XA as well
whoopsies why all right let's check that
out
okay there we go see so now what we get
is actual like pixel precise collision
instead of having um and of course we'll
just have to adjust that aesthetically
see they weren't actually being able to
go through that that's just how it's
gonna be on every floor and that's just
how it is with the normal collision here
but what we can do here is we can move
very very fast and we won't be going
through walls a collision also be
exactly the same which is good anyway
let's just let's just dumb this down to
about two just so we're a bit faster and
what I'll show you guys and we'll cover
slow-walking
next time just because we're running out
of time but if we got me twice as beat
if we go up to our tracer here you can
see starts chasing us and we can outrun
him and when we do he stops right see he
stopped he's chasing us and not we got
out of his range see so that's how that
works and you can see it's pretty cool
so that is that's gonna pretty much wrap
up episode 96 of game programming hope
you guys did enjoy this episode might be
a bit of a difficult concept across
shouldn't be okay but it uh it gets a
bit more involved as I said for um for
our next one which is uh well you know
slow stuff but and of course don't
forget that this is actually doing it
during an interval of one
so essentially you could argue that if
we set it to 2.5 it's really just gonna
be doing at a 3 instead of 2 point 5 for
the exhale 2 why but that's the way the
cookie crumbles let's probably second
time I said that bad idea but I'll see
you guys next time
goodbye
you